du cinéma la télévision du théâtre au
dessin animé en passant par la publicité
elle est désormais une figure
incontournable du paysage culturel
français tantôt opératrice elle devient
marilyn puis on la retrouve petite
souris ou bien dans la réplique à mr
bean visiblement elle ne fait que ce qui
lui plaît voici l'invité des cinq
dernières minutes
et s'est invité cfm à de caunes bonjour
madame merci d'être présente sur ce
plateau est ce qu'il vous plaît en ce
moment depuis hier soir en tout cas
c'est ce rendez vous que vous donnez au
théâtre la bruyère une pièce de théâtre
intitulée pour l'amour de gérard philipe
c'est une place une pièce pleine de
surprises de quoi ça parle exactement de
gérard philipe ou pas alors c'est une
pièce qui parle avant tout de
l'accomplissement de soi puisque c'est
donc ce jeune homme qui s'appelle
philippe gérard et non pas gérard
philipe ses parents auraient voulu qu'il
est injustement le même destin que face
à mr surtout aurait voulu qu'il est le
destin de gérard philipe le célèbre
acteur de fanfan la tulipe et le
problème c'est qu'il va naître avec un
défaut de fabrication il avec un seul
doigt à chacune de ses mains donc il
n'aura pas le destin que ses parents
rêvaient pour lui et il va décider de
prendre sa route et de et de se trouver
lui-même c'est-à-dire de devenir ce
qu'il est vraiment et il va se découvrir
un talent que je ne dévoilerai pas grâce
à ses deux doigts il sait faire un truc
un peu incroyable et il va il va en fait
vraiment s'épanouir au sein d'une
famille qui va choisir qui va choisir et
qu' une famille de cirque au milieu
d'eux au milieu de personnages
monstrueux et sublime un petit peu
loufoque quand même il plein de
surprises et je vous propose de regarder
un extrait justement qui a été tourné
hier soir pour la première au théâtre la
bruyère
s'il tombe il s'écrase s'il descend elle
le bout ce barrage et ont douze jeunes
talents trop tard il est presque au
centre du câble
s'il se crachent dessus c'en est fini de
lui c'en est fini ton numéro c'en est
fini de la demoiselle et du cirque sans
compter l'éclat de verre de cristal dans
l'oeil des spectateurs dont il ne reste
que demain comment ne sauras tu tout
cela si tu deviens man show déjà que tu
n'es pas folichon folichon nous sommes
très mal voeckler nous accueillons les
bras ouverts
max dont
il tombe sur le jeune homme est lourd ce
qui par leur mars vivent et souple le
sol tandis qu'ils les écrase tous deux
ils se remettront
alors à vos côtés sur scène on retrouve
le chanteur raphaël c'est sa première
expérience sur une scène de théâtre mais
il s'en sort plutôt pas mal comment ils
étaient hier soir avant le avant la
première aux îles et tetra que comme
nous tous comme nous tous il ya aussi
romain apelbaum bernard alane et sophie
arthur qui sont avec moi sur scène qui
sont des comédiens absolument fabuleux
et bar à saint louis les il était on
était tous au même diapason hier soir
c'est à dire un peu traqueux mais on a
eu une sale absolument
réjouit donc les gens sont sortis avec
la banane donc nous on était très très
content je crois que c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment une pièce qui qui célèbre
voilà qui s'est alors une fête dont on a
vu dans l'extrait on a vu un ours
il ya beaucoup de surprises dans la mise
en scène de pierre naud qui est l'auteur
de deux de ses nièces firmin qui est un
grand auteur à mon sens parce que c'est
juste un des listes pouvoir de pouvoir
dire ces mots qui sont à la fois féroce
drôle poétique
en tout cas il surprend beaucoup de
monde notamment par le décor il ya des
sons un peu un peu étonnant c'est un peu
surréaliste on dirait un tableau de dali
presque c'est intéressant je sais qu'il
a des références qui sont assez qui vont
du cinéma de fellini au burlesque des
marx brothers ce en passant par
il ya plein de petits clins d'oeil à
louis de funès à gérard philipe bien
entendu à chaplin donc il y a oui je
pense que c'est tant mieux tant mieux si
c'est un peu surréaliste alors le année
à des thèmes abordés dans cette pièce et
notamment la célébrité absolument
finalement c'est un thème contemporain
quoi c'est presque de la télé réalité
c'est le gérard philipe le philippe
gérard il pourrait jouer dans une
émission que l'on retrouve à la
télévision en ce moment et c'est à dire
que oui phocéen c'est un sujet toute
façon passionnant oui puisque tout le
monde court après devenir quelqu'un
ressembler à quelqu'un alors que l'idée
c'est d'essayer d'être soi même et de se
trouver soi-même et donc c'est vraiment
en saxe est une pièce qui parle de
l'accomplissement
comment faire quand on est avec un nom
de famille un peu lourd à porter et qui
et voilà j'allais justement pour les
villans mais je jure votre nom soit soit
silencieux sa portée très bien mais
est-ce que c'est un sujet qui vous a
concerné un moment de votre vie
justement le fait de pas forcément de
réussir mais en tout cas de ne pas
décevoir ses accents sais pas je choisi
la facilité bien sûr non mais moi je
suis absolument ravi de porter ce nom
dont je fais très très fier mais c'est
pas simple tous les jours de porter un
nom voilà quand il ya une filiation un
peu derrière donc donc c'est vraiment ça
aussi que le texte de pierre m'a
beaucoup touché ces voix là réussir à
devenir ce qu'on est vraiment choisir la
famille qu'on se choisit et s'accomplir
et célébrer vous parlez d'un
accomplissement vous êtes un peu une
touchette ou dans ce métier on vous a vu
dans des publicités on vous a vu
présenter des émissions à la télévision
au théâtre cinéma je crois même que vous
commencez a réalisé quelques courts
métrages ça veut dire que vous vous
cherchez encore ou pas ah non ça veut
dire que je m'amuse beaucoup et j'ai
besoin de ne pas m'ennuyer c'est un
petit peu mon la lutte quotidienne donc
j'essaye des choses parfois j'y arrive
parfois je me trompe mais voilà j'ai
cette chance de pouvoir faire
différentes choses donc ça ça me va très
bien en tout cas vous n'avez pas l'air
de vous ennuyer sur la sur la scène du
théâtre tellement fière dont dans cet
amour que vous déclarez donc
gérard philipe ça se joue jusqu'au mois
de mai je joue vite court jusqu'en juin
à la bruyère une pièce de pierre note au
théâtre la bruyère merci beaucoup merci
alain decaux n'est venu nous voir sur ce
plateau